[Musique]
on être invités du jour c'est vous
pascal boniface bonjour vous êtes
directeur fondateur de l'institut des
relations internationales et
stratégiques iris auteur de nombreux
ouvrages notamment aux racailles m pour
le monde occidental relever le défi
troll aux éditions eyrolles merci d'être
avec nous il ya ce rendez-vous un don on
va commencer peut-être pas reparlé cet
après midi à la demande des américains
rendez vous à new york donc pour le
conseil de sécurité de l'onu qu'est-ce
qu'on peut qu est ce qu on doit on
attendre aujourd'hui
ça sera encore des conversations mais je
ne pense pas qu'il à l'issue de la crise
tu sais cette réunion dans tous les cas
le contact diplomatique est maintenu et
des règles essentielles il est important
de maintenir ce contact pour essayer de
faire baisser un petit peu les tensions
et d'éviter une nouvelle escalade donc
effectivement il n'ya en fait pas de
percée significative mais le fait que le
contact soit maintenue et qu'en même
essentiel encore faut-il que le rendez
vous avait lieu pour le moment les
recyots pose apparemment
oui mais en même temps on sait qu'il ya
des négociations de toute façon et que
les russes veulent avoir un lien direct
avec les américains que le conseil de
sécurité plutôt une enceinte qui leur
plaît d'habitude mais peut-être aussi
veulent dire dire que c'est une affaire
bilatérale entre les états unis et le et
que ça ne concerne pas l'ensemble du
conseil de sécurité qui n'est pas une
affaire onusienne mais c'est une affaire
européenne
d'où cette annonce aux scouts téléphone
qui aura lieu demain ça fait beaucoup
d'annoncés en amont saga lavrov et
anthony blinken devons donc décroché le
téléphone pour se parler pour se dire
cours exactement
je pense pour répéter chacun les
positions et peut-être trouvé essayer de
trouver d'avancer vers une solution qui
leur étaient à chacun de sortir la tête
hors piste est bien de ça dont il est
question du côté américain il est
inenvisageable de dire que l'ukraine ne
rentrera jamais en votant même si ce
n'est c'est le moins que l'on puisse
dire pas une priorité mais du côté russe
il est important de dire que ils n'ont
pas fait tout cette gesticulation pour
rien et qu'ils ont obtenu quelque chose
qu'il s'agisse du déploiement d'armes
américaines dans l'ukraine du nom
stationnement de troupes américaines
dans l'ukraine et donc d'engagement de
tout est de savoir s'il y est déjà temps
de pouvoir trouver cette solution ou
chacun fait encore un peu monter les
enchères en espérant obtenir un peu plus
et espère bien de la gesticulation du
côté américain hayden de montrer qu'il
est bien le chef de l'alliance
atlantique mais aussi faire taire treuil
montrer à trump du républicain qu'il est
bien ce qui fait preuve de fermeté à
l'égard de la russe c'est d'ailleurs
aussi peut être pour ça que joe biden va
recevoir aujourd'hui à la maison blanche
l'émir du qatar pour par les
approvisionnements en gaz pour pour
l'europe on a le sentiment qu'il est
déjà dans le coup d'après après encore
un oui effectivement les américains
disent que eux mêmes sont prêts à
fournir du gaz liquide aux européens
c'est tout le problème de la dépendance
européenne à l'égard du gaz russe mais
en même temps les russes n'ont pas
tellement intérêt à jouer sans larmes du
casse parce que même si à courteille ils
peuvent se passer ils ont 600 milliards
de dollars de réserves du fait de
l'augmentation du prix du gaz et du
pétrole ils peuvent se passer pour
quelques mois de la vente de gaz et de
pétrole à l'europe mais pas sur le long
terme leur crédibilité en tant
qu'exportateur serait atteint ce qu'ils
voulaient couper le gaz à l'égard de
l'europe donc il ya en fait une double
dépendance la russie a besoin du marché
européen est pour l'instant l'europe a
besoin du gaz russe on a le sentiment
quand même que depuis le début de cette
crise il a comme était beaucoup question
de posture assez stricte et côté
américain et côté russe est ce qu'on
n'est pas allé trop loin est ce qu'il
n'est pas temps tout simplement de
mettre la crise sur pause aujourd'hui
oui ça serait bien sûr tout à fait
apprécié alors on n'est pas allé trop
loin dans la mesure où les arts n'ont
pas parlé on sera allé trop loin le
moment où les armes par l'eau on sait
qu'un dérapage est vite arrivé pardonnez
moi mais quand on parle de déploiement
de milliers de troupes le dérapage il
faut pas grand chose pour que pour qu'il
arrive et il peut y avoir une
provocation il pu avoir un mauvais
calcul effectivement le dérapage peut
arriver très rapidement quand il ya un
tel amas d'armes et d'hommes aux
frontières mais pour l'instant en fait
effectivement ils sont allés trop loin
dans la mesure où cela prend des
proportions qui aurait pensé que cela
prenne de telles proportions et que l'on
parle de nouveau du risque de guerre en
europe donc c'est quelque chose que l'on
pensait être dépassé mais en même temps
la rationalité peut encore l'emporter
chacun a intérêt en fait personne n'a
intérêt la guerre la guerre serait une
catastrophe pour tout le monde on peut
espérer que on est dans une période
gesticulations de démonstration
diplomatico militaire je comprends tout
à fait aux arguments effectivement
malheureusement un dérapage peut
toujours arriver mais pour le pour
l'instant on montre plutôt ses muscles
pour n'avoir pas à s'en servir et les
britanniques eux aussi dans tout ça se
range dans le camp évidemment de leur
allié américain boris johnson qui a
déclaré ce week end jour un vaste
déploiement de troupes à l'europe à
l'est de l'europe même carrément doubler
ses effectifs ils sont actuellement 1150
home depot y en a pris à quelques
instants que il y aurait un statement
une déclaration devant le parlement
britannique sur sur la crise et
craignait la position des britanniques
aujourd'hui ce qu'elle vous étonne non
elle est logique du point de vue de bree
johnson qui d'une part à d'importants
problèmes de politique intérieure et
donc faire une diversion au niveau
géopolitique est le bienvenu est par
ailleurs depuis le brésil la grande
bretagne veut retrouver un nouveau rôle
est donc le fait de montrer aux
américains eux mêmes s'ils ne sont plus
au sein de l'union européenne il reste
quand même toujours leurs meilleurs
alliés et que washington a toujours
besoin de londres au sein de l'otan
parce qu'ils sont plus proches et plus
fiable du comique washington que
l'allemagne et la france est aussi un
calcul de la part de ben johnson une
dernière question c'est un peu celle que
tout le monde se pose en ce moment
est-ce que vous pensez que l'issue est
proche l'issue pacifiste évidemment non
pas forcément parce que chacun peut
encore attendre on trouvera une issue
quand tout le monde aura deux coups à
prier victoire et en même temps ensemble
il faut pas qu'il y ait un camp qu'ils
aient le sentiment qu'ils aient perdu la
partie il n'acceptera pas la solution et
il n'est pas certain qu'on ait peut-être
qu'il aura une percée soudaine mais ce
type de solution peut encore prendre
quelques temps pour être trouvé merci
beaucoup pascal boniface vous étiez
notre invité du jour on va évidemment
suivre attentivement les prochaines
séances échéant cette prise de parole
devant le parlement britannique
cette réunion du conseil de sécurité de
l'onu également cet après midi à new
york